encore la même situation mètres
nous réfléchissons à partir d'aujourd'hui
de ce qui a été accumulé
mais aussi ce dont nous avons besoin
technique
à l'infini
sujet spécifique de cette convention
ou de cette édition est la préservation de
mémoire historique et patrimoine
culturel nous attachons une grande importance
juste au moment où, pratiquement,
monde qui consiste à effacer un peu le
la mémoire ou l'histoire qu'ils créent
propre peuple est ce qui a conduit à
que nous sommes là où nous sommes, disons
D'une manière générale, le développement de
l'humanité et c'est précisément ce dont il s'agit
a consacré cette édition à cet événement et
Outre le rôle joué par les médias
communication pour préserver cette mémoire
et cet héritage
comme égal
et regardez les pays promus 38 pays
représentés et un total de 150
délégués étrangers et un total de 245
national si toutes les provinces
absolument toutes les provinces et non
seulement les provinces mais aussi
les communes faisant une sélection
bien sûr à la fois de la radio et de
la télévision pour qu'elle ne reste pas
aucun des deux moyens en dehors du
Quels sont les sujets qui allaient être abordés ?
les deux ici ne devraient pas jouer
l'histoire disparaît avec certains
symboles